For experts in emotion interview.
We have the honor of speaking with Dr Jonathan Rottenberg.
Um,
a leading researcher in the area of emotion and psychopathology.
Jonathan Rottenberg has pioneered efforts to integrate the basic science of
emotion with the study of psychopathology.
He received his phd from Stanford University and is currently an associate
professor of psychology at the University of South Florida where he directs the
mood and emotion laboratory.
He's the lead editor of an n of emotion and psychopathology,
bridging [inaudible] and clinical science.
And he's authored over 30 scientific publications.
His work,
not surprisingly focused on depression as well as crying,
has received international media coverage,
including science news,
Scientific American,
the New York Times,
ABC News,
and the BBC.
He also writes a blog about depression for psychology today.
Um,
one fun fact about Jonathan Rottenberg is that he decided in his early forties,
he was going to train for a marathon and by the time we'll speak with him,
he'll have already run three during that time.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Jonathan
Rottenberg,
answering the question of,
is crying actually good for us?
Oh,
welcome John.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thank you for having me.
What I'd love to hear from you as we get our conversation going today is a
little bit about your journey into emotions.
So what first got you started and that hooked on studying emotion?
Well,
I went to a graduates at Stanford and I was arriving there in the late nineties.
And emotion was actually very hot
topic,
new theories or new journals like the journal emotion coming out.
And I had the good fortune of working with uh,
James Gross to an expert on emotional regulation.
And what really excited me was the possibility of combining all of these
methods,
logical methods.
We're starting motion new methods for studying emotional behavior,
uh,
combining these methods with local research.
Um,
Ian garlic was also a Stanford than the late nineties when I was there.
And I thought this was an incredible opportunity because here we have used
remarkable pools that were increasingly understood as eventually break rooms
burned setting in motion.
Uh,
and then we also have a clinical disorder,
a major depressive disorder,
which is very much defined by changes in mood,
in motion.
Um,
only only problem was there wasn't very much research.
And so I saw this,
uh,
using tools.
It's a way to understand in some ways what was the most important of what I
would argue is the most important disorder,
um,
in terms of burden,
in terms of
recurrence and just rob prep prevalence.
So,
um,
I got hooked at that moment and I've stayed ever since.
And I mean,
since you got hooked,
I mean,
you've just conducted some of the most profound discoveries into really
understanding,
you know,
what is going on in individuals who are suffering from depression.
What are the emotional eyes that these individuals and also about the phenomena,
you know,
that may be particularly prevalent in individuals who are depressed.
But it's actually something really common to all of us,
which is crying.
And so I'd love to start out asking you some questions about your research.
Um,
first,
first with the topic of crying so we can all,
you know,
readily recall times in our own lives.
And we were crying.
And many of us seem to have these beliefs that when we've cried in some way,
this has been beneficial for us in some way,
it's been cathartic or helpful to kind of cleanse us of our negative emotional
experiences.
Um,
but your work is really,
really exciting here in that it suggests that actually that belief may not
always be true and that crying is not necessarily and always adaptive for us.
So I was wondering if you could share some of your own scientific observations
and findings that sort of now provide a roadmap for helping us understand when
crying is and is not necessarily beneficial or adaptive.
Sure.
New growing is one of the most dramatic emotional behaviors from when we first
started out as a little bit maybe to the end of life.
And it spreads through that whole life force in one thing that is particularly
salient about crime is that,
uh,
has a distinctive socially,
salient,
a signal name.
We fears.
And so we certainly noticed when we cry,
other people certainly notice when we cry.
And so many people have strong opinions about what happens when bad cry or when
other people cry.
And like you said,
there is a very strong leg week.
They crying is started.
And so that is reflected on surveys.
People
equal important,
yes.
And not just being a contrarion but we're really wanting to understand what
extent crime is and is not Cathartic.
Um,
we talk a little bit deeper and so we used the,
have you used a number of different designs from experimental designs?
You survey with designs,
the daily diary designs too.
I try to look at a one and were crying,
might be having a benefits,
might be Cathartic.
And what we've discovered over the years since that not all tying episodes of
liquidity.
I,
so what I mean by that is that a number of things determine,
uh,
whether or not crying it's going to be associated with,
that's a one years,
um,
we context in which firing occurs.
Um,
and some of these findings maybe aren't so surprising.
but we just at the end would really want to qualify the idea that when you cry
and feel better,
as it turns out,
that when you look at crying in the moment or frying and the daily diary design,
it's really a minority of the crying episode that are associated with improving.
So ones that are are ones in which situation really changes as a function of the
fine.
So social factors.
So do people actually come to the side of the person's crying and crying has its
power to draw another.
So those episodes that are drying and others tend to be associated with frying
upsets in which the situation changes,
uh,
um,
seem to be associated with mood benefits.
Um,
and finally the,
the aspect of stayed in the crier seems to really make a difference.
And this is a one connection to depression,
depressed people.
It turns out,
and people who are very anxious and not report,
they brine benefits their mood that tremendously.
So,
um,
yes,
crying if anything is associated with mood benefits,
not our frying episodes are upgraded before.
And it seemed that both social,
Eric Rustic Sam,
the characteristics of the fryer make a big difference in shaping whether or not
that frying it's sure any bathroom at all.
Well,
it's so interesting because you alluded to depression and you know,
when we start our interview I said,
you know,
depression for many people is this sort of,
quintessential example of,
you know,
profound crying,
right?
And so many people think of crying and depression as synonymous,
but your experiments really challenged some of these big assumptions about how
depression actually alters crying.
Um,
and so I wonder if you could say a little bit about,
in what ways does crying behavior provide a window into understanding what might
actually be disturbed in depression?
Sure.
Yeah.
Um,
and this is sort of as a story,
uh,
um,
beings prize you guys.
When I started out,
I thought that our research would confirm,
um,
what's in the Dsm,
the diagnostic manual,
uh,
it's used by clinicians everywhere in the surface,
defines part of depression as increased brine behavior.
And so I thought,
um,
what,
what are we learning is in what ways this Prac at this depression magnify the
time response.
And if we wanted to use again these nuclear emotion,
so multimap that a research study,
emotional experience,
emotional behavior in emotion related physiology,
bringing depress people into a lab parent,
they're crying.
So does non depressed people.
And the data didn't really cooperate as what we found was that contrary to DSM
brass,
people were no more likely to cry.
The sad student lesson,
perhaps Renner's thing we changed is associated with that crying.
We're actually diminished in depressed people said their physiological response
then frying like that sweat gland activity.
We're actually the last,
yeah,
those are the non-depressed people.
And then we'd start to look at other,
uh,
I kind of gained this assistant then what we saw near Dari or original analysis
that they've have wherever we look fresh and seem to shrink rather than magnify
the effects of crime.
And so this really made me think about what,
what,
what's in the DSM needs observations that permission to have a years.
And I got that they're simply wrong.
It's not that they're wrong,
it's that they're making those observations in particular context.
So someone comes in,
they're depressed,
we're being evaluated and gas,
you see crying behavior.
But I think what we weren't in the experimental work when you present normative,
so we kind of stimuli that mixed the average person crimes.
Like I'm the champ or this is dreadful.
At that scene,
little boy is ripped apart by this incredible loss.
Those kind of more and more cry lessons.
Private listening situations don't eat a lot or the people.
Uh,
and so what it makes me think is that the things that are listed in brass,
people's buying or like we'd be different then what are things that are
listening?
I,
everyone else is crying.
And so this notion,
again of the context really making a big difference.
I'm thinking,
well,
so depressed people reporting to furnish and that they're having a lot of crime
in any crime by themselves and we need prying into their pillow.
They may be crying because God or some person isn't helping them.
It's not that there are particular sad things in their environment that are
prompting Brian.
We don't even need necessarily a provocation.
So that gives us sort of a different understanding of what,
what the statements and the Bsi might mean and what the change is in motion.
Um,
if depressed people experience and it might reflect,
I mean,
in what you're alluding to is another theme in your work,
which really suggests that the emotional nature and lives of individuals with
depression are quite different from those who aren't currently depressed or
maybe don't have a history of being depressed.
And I think you found that the emotions that these individuals experience with
suppression don't quite fit their current environmental context,
which you have referred to as this emotion contexts and sensitivity.
And I wonder what you see as some of the most promising discoveries from this
model you developed,
um,
that might help us better understand the nature of emotion in depression.
Sure.
Um,
so I've been talking about this emotion context sensitivity since like 2005 and
since that time,
you know,
there had been another other researchers who wrote replicated this finding,
which was essentially that depressed people don't report and display the
normative changes that you would expect to see,
whether it's positive emotions or situations or negative emotion or emotions or
situations that depressed people are getting this flattened profile of response
or the stereotypic.
Um,
so I think that's,
at this point we can say that that real,
that we found it and not get enough studies and consistently lacrosse labs.
And so we're really looking at a new set of next questions,
which is whether this really about what does this reflect for the proximal
mechanism,
whether they're at cognitive mechanisms out of the thought,
whether they're behavioral mechanisms,
whether their physiological,
now I can use that,
explained this pad and that generated this pattern in a second.
Um,
he set of questions.
I think that also speaks to the meaning,
uh,
of this pattern is what is its relationship to the clinical symptoms that you'd
see in depression.
So depression with an episodic disorder,
uh,
so it could be diagnosable.
You have at least five of nine symptoms.
Unethical people typically will be an episode for some months at a time,
like better and we'll have welfare.
It's so we see this pattern of UCI,
uh,
during depressive episodes and have people have looked,
um,
I've not seen very often that it,
that it's there after the depressive episodes and people who are burning very
well.
Now we're studying children.
Uh,
and one of our,
um,
one of our aims is to understand whether the CCI pattern might be an antecedent,
the depression.
Essentially what we're trying to understand or unpack is whether these and
emotion might have some causal relationship,
um,
to,
to the clinical syndrome of depression.
It's possible that they're actually not important.
Um,
it didn't causation of episodes of depression,
but they might be more important in the maintenance,
uh,
of depression.
That is how long depression last.
So we found that,
um,
the extent to which a person shows the CCF pattern seems to predict the duration
of the episode.
So this suggests that even if it's not a causal in explaining why person becomes
depressed in the first place.
So it might be quite important in terms of how quickly the depression gets
dissolved.
And so I think there are,
um,
some potential implications for both understanding treatments,
how existing treatments we're defining those treatments and incorporating motion
into our conceptualization of treating I think is another huge area of
opportunity.
Yeah.
That was when you were talking,
I mean it makes you wonder how much you can translate these really promising
findings into aiding issues such as you alluded to treatment or differential
diagnosis or identifying people who would benefit from,
you know,
different types of emotion related interventions.
Yeah,
I think there's a lot of opportunity where we neuro some work by people like
Andy,
the marking okay.
I think is very important.
First steps and speed and understand our existing treatments,
treatments that are reasonably reasonably robust and successful.
Most treatments change in motion.
And so simply a pre and post designs where we have people,
um,
acid on different aspects of their emotional functioning in episode buyer.
Yeah.
Initiation treatment down the same people fasted when the treatment was
successful.
I though it would be quite interesting compare uh,
emotion and between those two a arts success 40 and not successfully treated.
Um,
because right now I think we mostly have assumptions about how treatments for
depression,
change,
immersion experience behavior and rushing belt for writing physiology and in
different contexts.
But we don't have as much data as you might.
Um,
if you might think.
And part of it is because people who do death broke crowds and people would be
based in research are often different people and they're very protective of the
patients who are in the drug bouts in assassins of motion.
We started seeing this mocking around,
um,
well from my pig and development perspective,
we need basic science.
I think it's absolutely essential to understand just the script up room and
that's just not even getting the question.
And you're talking guidance using,
uh,
using some emotion data as a predictor of what kind of greeting the Persian
chick yet.
But it should this person I get CBT,
cognitive behavioral therapy or should they get any depressants?
So what,
what specific brand of anti depressant or specific s well,
within five minutes behavioral therapy,
I think ultimately that would be tremendously exciting and important as well.
What we have right now,
it's a big problem of not knowing are what the,
what the patients most likely to respond to them.
You have the fresh and the good news number of Pittman,
uh,
efficacious treatments now,
but none of them are back there for everyone.
I'll have fairly high nonresponse or incomplete complete response rates.
And so anything we can do to increase the efficiency of equation Nancy used to
me that emotion data will be very high on the list of data that you could,
I mean,
so you've touched on some really important themes about where we need to go
next,
right?
In of really delineating and mapping out this research to aid and facilitate
diagnosis and treatment.
Um,
when you think broadly about the field of emotion,
I know we've talked about crying and depression and emotion and treatment today,
where do you see the field of emotion more generally headed as it sort of moves
into the future?
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean,
I think my work is part of the first wave,
uh,
integrating,
um,
basic for research and science,
with clinical signs.
And I think there are very much needs to be a second one.
So part of the first wave was saying we're here,
we can do this.
Um,
but developing more mature and robust and sustainable.
So for example,
with my own research with DCI,
okay,
we've definitely shown that there is a pattern and that it's,
it's good to show with a robust not beds,
um,
with multiple mastheads that there was a certain pattern.
Now we need to go back and go to the next,
the next step.
And I've mentioned a few of the,
I think there'll be involved,
but I think,
or this could be true for every different classes where it's at as novelists
research going on the notion it's raining.
And I think that,
you know,
is sort of in some ways the model or where the field needs to go.
Understanding for example,
uh,
individual symptoms and it's feeding like Anhedonia or neglect.
I understand.
When does that happen?
What does that reflect,
you know,
the late,
um,
clinical improvement in speed?
So I really,
I think that
it's a matter of continuing to do what we've been doing.
I don't think that we need,
I think we're on a good,
uh,
on a good road.
Um,
but I'm not losing focus or energy.
and so I'll do my best.
You might smell fart and move it's order with them setting.
But I think that there's many opportunities in parallel.
Um,
I should say also,
um,
belatedly that what can happen is you do more explicit in Paris.
And so now we have the descriptions of what's happening in individual disorders,
explicit comparison between disorders.
Um,
I think we have much more to go on the,
for example,
airing what's adding to we see in depression with,
uh,
those of anxiety,
whether it's your neighbor conditions that are I lake or morbid suffer with
depression and understand what's similar,
what's different,
um,
w in terms of what,
how emotion changes and needs to that conditions.
So then when you speak to students who are just thinking now about embarking in
this field of emotion,
what kind of advice would you give them?
Or have you given them
trust your instincts?
I mean,
I,
I would give them concrete advice boards so there would be to trust their
intent.
I don't think I would have that any success at all if I didn't listen to me
instance initially back crying.
So it's something I read in the BSM and I was like,
well what does that really reflect?
What does it really mean?
What's,
what,
what would that based on?
And I learned it wasn't really based on our research.
So I thought,
let's do a research study.
And one thing led to another.
And so student has an insight like that.
Even if it's not fully baked,
um,
they should backed on that.
And,
and,
uh,
the contradictory thing is that at the same time,
I think you have to,
um,
be able to integrate feedback,
the mentors.
So,
but both things can be true.
So you can very much think that you have a good idea.
Um,
but what the,
what is the job?
And you can stick to your guns.
But what it,
what it meant work and help you do is shape that idea and help you see,
well,
what can I really learn?
Or what are the limitations or,
um,
because I think that science has always this juggling a unit or emotion of
different than other areas of science between being not novel.
So having ideas did the field who's going to need to listen,
to assimilate with,
uh,
founder dating to what's already known.
And so a good student is going to both be wanting to push the envelope and
simple what we already know,
but also finding ways to accommodate what they're finding,
um,
with,
with what we already know.
And it never ends.
So it after your get your phd and you're on your postdoc or in your first
faculty position,
or if you've got,
then you're a full professor.
You're just thinking professional,
doesn't matter.
This will just predicting predicament will always be true where you have to
develop new ideas but also understand the context.
And most of those ideas are happening.
So graduate school,
just the first,
first in some way,
most demonic place in which that,
uh,
that process unfolds.
And some of it is that many students feel like they don't know anything.
Um,
but the truth is that,
you know,
even now the fields of emotions a little bit more mature and there's still vast
area,
it's where we really don't know much,
much,
much more than not knowing one.
And so they should feel very confident that they can make a contribution.
Well,
thank you so much for speaking with us today,
John.
It was wonderful.
I was by flasher with breastfeeding.
Always good talking to you.
So this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Jonathan
Rottenberg from the University of South Florida.
Thank you again.